they don't got the best looking women  out there but Alan what are you into  what type of girls do you like uh the  pretty ones the pretty ones do you think  there's just something that happens here  in the water I try to get shot by dude  I'm talking about my mother  there are certain women here that they  look like the fish at the bottom of the  ocean like an angler fish  typically um  I mean very beautiful English women not  as much you think my mom's from Scotland  your mom great kids  I mean it's facts bro why do you think  I'm six too you should have been sucking  more  you sucked yourself to five seven I need  you to grow up you know my mom is a very  attractive woman from Scotland like a  six in America but like a Scottish